tenemos este problema dice los
triángulos que se muestran son
congruentes semejantes o ninguna de las
dos
bueno empecemos con congruentes para que
dos figuras en el plano sean congruentes
deben de tener la misma forma y el mismo
tamaño es decir podemos girar o voltear
una idea y pasar la ola a la otra nada
más moviéndose bueno en el caso de los
triángulos lo que necesitamos es que
tengan lados correspondientes iguales y
ángulos correspondientes iguales pero se
ve que aquí eso no va a pasar porque
todos los lados del triángulo j k l
miden 5 y todos los lados del triángulo
x 7 también 7.5 así que no los
triángulos no pueden ser congruentes de
hecho se ve a simple vista que el
triángulo x jay-z es más grande bueno
vamos a ver si son semejantes para que
dos cosas sean semejantes pues pueden
tener diferente tamaño pero deben tener
la misma forma en el caso de los
triángulos podemos pensar en eso de dos
formas distintas una es ver que las
parejas de lados correspondientes tienen
la misma razón
o bien también podemos ver que los
ángulos correspondientes son iguales
vamos a ver primero lo de los ángulos
mira en este triángulo tenemos estos
tres ángulos marcados como iguales este
es igual a este que es igual a este y
como en un triángulo la suma de los
ángulos que es 180 cada uno de estos
triángulos mide 60 vale 60 60 y 60 y lo
mismo pasa aquí son tres ángulos iguales
que suman 180 así que cada uno mide 60
grados de esta forma tenemos que este
ángulo es igual a este este es igual a
este y este es igual a este y por lo
tanto los triángulos si son semejantes
esta es una forma de pensarlo otra forma
de pensarlo es haciendo las razones
entre los lados déjame ponerle que jk es
el lado correspondiente al xy en este
caso podrían ser otros porque porque
todos los lados de este miden lo mismo y
de este también pero vamos a tomar jk
con xy entonces vamos a ver cuánto es la
razón jk
jk entre equis y pues eso simplemente es
igual a 5 entre 7.5 pero si nos damos
cuenta esa es exactamente la misma razón
que cae le cae le entristece está verdad
otra vez es 5 entre 7.5 es igual a kl
entre eta y también tenemos que es igual
a
zx bueno no lj voy a poner primero el
del lado chiquito porque así tiene que
ir l j l j
/ zx aunque entonces ahora sí 13 está x
lj / zx y por lo tanto la proporción de
correspondiente entre cada pareja de
lados es la misma y así tenemos que los
triángulos también son semejantes por
esa razón vale entonces una razón son
los ángulos los ángulos correspondientes
son iguales y otra razón es que las
parejas correspondientes tienen la misma
razón
bueno entonces ya nada más quiero decir
otro comentario adicional acerca de la
congruencia resulta que la congruencia
es algo más fuerte que la semejanza en
la semejanza basta tener tres ángulos
iguales pero para la congruencia también
los tres lados tienen que ser iguales
entonces pues bueno tenemos que la
congruencia congruencia
implica la semejanza e implica las
semejanzas me cansa si tenemos dos
triángulos que son congruentes entonces
también son semejantes así que pues
déjame ponerlo así de hecho podemos
pensarlo visualmente como que aquí están
todas las parejas del triángulo que son
semejantes semejantes vale y aquí
adentro viven las que son la de los
triángulos que son congruentes si las
parejas de triángulos congruentes
congruentes si tenemos que dos
triángulos son congruentes entonces son
semejantes pero al revés no
necesariamente es cierto como nos
muestra este problema vale bueno le voy
a dejar hasta aquí nos vemos hasta la
próxima